[Music]
thank you
it was just one minute and he was
telling me that
I should not worry but at the same time
I could hear that he was in his voice
that he was about to cry and that there
were people present in the room while he
was calling me telling him something in
another language that I didn't
understand and just after one minute he
hanged up
thank you
to fight for waterless release is not
only so important for his own safety and
life but also for the the freedom of
speech and expression
foreign
there has been no direct contact between
me and Taliban I do not know his
condition I do not know how he's treated
if he's well
if he's getting food or clothing
um
and this really worries me
[Music]
just I just want my my husband back home
that that's all in the end
[Music]